[موسيقى]
والخيمه هذه اللي درتها هنايا السبان
تاعها التماسك الاجتماعي يكون هذا هو
الشيء اللي نحوص عليه انا نحوس على واحد
التماسك الاجتماعي نشات الخيمه هادي
والحمد لله راني استقبل في الناس الضيافه
[موسيقى]
قديم الزمن ملي نعقل هذه الارض مليلين زدت
انا
راني
57 اللي زدت نعقل على هذا البلاصه كانت
عندي حنيني ولا يشدها بويا
اللي لقيته قديم راني نحافظ عليه
البويا وبويا ورثه لي وانا الليهم
[موسيقى]
الحريره ندير منه الكسره وندير منه الخبز
المهم الحوايج التقاليد القديمه راني
محافظ عليها وشادها
عليهم ماشي به
[موسيقى]
باي طريقه نستقبلوا
المردوم ولا ندير له
كلشي تبارك الله كاين الناس
وما عندي اي مشكله فيها
[موسيقى]
الاثار القديمه دايرها تما نوريها للجيل
هذا
المقتنيات هادو كامل لم يكمل من القصر
عندنا وانا نحافظ على هاد الحوايج من زمان
نبغيهم انا لهاد الناس
انتقاليد نتاع المنطقه هذه كيفاش عايشه
وكيفاش كانت عايشه
[موسيقى]
انا الهدف نتاعي باغي نوري التقاليد نتاع
المنطقه نتاعي وانتاع بلادي
اللي عشتو
[موسيقى]